a team of researchers analyzed 27
million news articles published between
1970 and 2019 and what they found was
that use of words like sexist and racist
in the New York Times and in The Wider
liberal media increased over 400 percent
since 2012. obviously sexism and racism
have not actually increased 400 since
2012. it's only the media's use of these
terms that's increased
your writing is so good dude people send
me that audience capture article all the
time this most recent one that you did
about uh how smart people make
themselves be dumb The Tick Tock article
it's it's phenomenal I I
you're the only sub stack that I pay for
and uh thanks quite rightly quite
rightly what can I say so my favorite
thing to do with your Twitter is go
through some of the mental models biases
and ideas that you've got and we're
going to go through as many as we can
today first one is chilling effect when
punishment for what people say becomes
widespread people stop saying what they
really think and instead say whatever is
needed to thrive in the social
environment thus limits on speech become
limits on sincerity
yeah so I mean
so this is you know a sort of very
timely thing I think because there's a
lot of talk about sort of suppressing
people from social media and stuff and
um I think people should really realize
that stopping people from airing their
true opinions doesn't change their
opinions it just makes them mask their
opinions
um and when this happens at scale it can
lead to all kinds of absurd situations
uh like the Abilene Paradox I don't know
if we've covered the Abilene Paradox run
it back it's basically a situation yeah
it's basically a situation where
everyone professes a belief that no one
actually believes purely because they
think everybody else believes it and so
you can have a situation where literally
everybody just is saying stuff that is
just not true for the sole reason that
they think everybody else thinks it's
true an example of this
um would probably be considered sort of
um the issue of what a woman is
um you've got pretty much everybody
in the mainstream culture now pretending
that they don't know what a woman is
um but if you were to ask these people
in private they would probably be able
to tell you they'll just probably say an
adult human female but because there's
this sort of stigma now around knowing
what a woman is
people you know basically sort of have
to pretend like they don't know and uh
it's just it leads to absurd situation
after absurd situation and that's why I
think it's
it's I mean there's many reasons there's
many arguments against censorship but
this is definitely one of the strongest
I think
um you're not by censoring people you're
not changing their behavior changing
their opinions you're not changing their
beliefs all you're doing is just sort of
sweeping them under the carpet you know
and they're just going to continue just
you just won't be able to see it anymore
so you can't keep track of these people
anymore this ties into your view about
uh when people are their opinions they
feel like they have to have an opinion
on anything and everything and changing
your opinion is tantamount to
destruction of yourself so because
people value their opinions so much
in this situation quite rightly you're
um the performative nature
of having the right opinion of the
Abilene paradox
playing along with that has never been
more important because opinions have
never been more relevant to our status
within the world
yeah absolutely and you see this
reflected most in the precisely the
industries that you would expect it to
be reflected in I.E the industries that
are image oriented so if you have a look
at people who have the most fashionable
opinions I mean Rob Henderson would
probably call these luxury beliefs
they're sort of you know fashionable
opinions that people adopt in order to
sort of signal status
um you know when I was a kid
uh we all used to like buy sweatshirts
which had like brand names stamped
across the front of them like you know
Fila or Nike you know when you're a kid
at school because you want everybody to
know that you paid paid for it so
nowadays when you get older you no
longer wear these labels now it's
opinions instead uh you know you have
the she her and the he him instead of
poor Han poor Femme you know and um it's
sort of like
you see this in Hollywood you see it
amongst Hollywood actors you see it
amongst academics you see it in politics
you see in all of the industries where
image is important where basically
appearing to have the right opinions is
more important than actually having the
correct opinions yes and it's also an
industry where opinions and actions have
never been more diverged right you know
somebody now can have a Twitter account
that proselytizes the right uh beliefs
and in private a whole completely
different beliefs or the way that they
go about living their lives be totally
different you could be a an online vegan
who's an offline carnivore and for as
long as the twine shall never meet
uh it kind of doesn't really matter so
much whereas in the past your ability to
profess a belief that you didn't live up
to in reality would have been much more
difficult to diverge especially in
before the internet right or before
print media there is no way for you your
opinions are very much your actions
right there is no way to do this and to
bifurcate you and what you say from what
you and what you are and what you do so
yeah it's
um
the opportunity and the motive have
aligned to uh create this chilling
effect
yeah absolutely people have what their
digital age has done is it's separated
the person from the persona
um so now you know there's a much wider
Gulf between how you appear to others
and how you actually are than there ever
was because of the sort of importance of
social media in our daily lives and so
because of that sort of dissociation
there's now big Gulf between
the beliefs that people profess and
what they actually believe in real life
there's no consequences nowadays for
what a person actually believes really
and most of the time anyway at least as
long as you have the fashion opinions
you know if you have unfashionable
opinions then there is consequences but
if you if you believe something like for
instance um
uh that
it's not a problem for
um
like for instance there was this issue
in Scotland recently about um that there
was a rapist who was locked in a women's
prison briefly and then there's an
outcry about it over the Internet which
sort of LED Nicholas sturgeon to walk it
back and may have led to a resignation
um but I mean if you're like her a
really really sort of uh
rich
Hollywood actor
um and you you know you you've got no
you know nobody who's going to go to
prison there's nobody in your life who's
ever gone to prison or anything like
that uh you don't need to worry about
anybody you know being hurt by your
opinions on whether women should because
whether a trans rapist should be allowed
in a woman's prison so you're not paying
the consequences other people are paying
the consequences and you could say the
same thing about black crime rates or
whatever you know people say that
um you know black people are being shot
at a disproportionate rate
um by police
um and that this is purely due to
systemic racism
um you know if you're a Hollywood actor
you don't need to worry about uh the
true causes of the sort of uh crime
rates in in like neighborhoods so you
could just say yeah
yeah or the outcomes of defunding the
police right defund the police this is a
perfect example of this say it but yeah
yours isn't the neighborhood where you
need police in any case Okay so next one
epistemic humility instead of trying to
be right try to be less wrong the
investor Charlie Munger said it is
remarkable how much long-term Advantage
People Like Us have gotten by trying to
be consistently not stupid instead of
trying to be very intelligent avoiding
idiocy is much simpler than achieving
genius so it's easier to turn it into a
habit furthermore if we try to be right
then we'll often convince ourselves
we're right even if we're not but if we
begin from the position that we're wrong
and we Sim we try to be less wrong we
gain more awareness in our blind spots
and become less wedded to our beliefs
reducing our resistance to learning
yeah so this has got wide applications I
use this in every Endeavor really um
particular one that I found is very
useful was my approach to writing
because when I first started writing I
used to try to sound smart I tried to be
intelligent
and what this led to was me using a lot
of really fancy words a lot of big words
so instead of using the word tiptoe I
would use the word digitigrade you know
and I'd use all these other really long
words that people just didn't know what
I was talking about and because they
didn't know what I was talking about
what actually happened was that by
trying to be smart
I became less clear in my communication
so I basically I was becoming more
stupid
and people had less understanding of
what I was trying to say so it backfired
and it was then that I realized that
actually good writing is not about
trying to sound smart it's about
avoiding sounding stupid by just using
you know you can use Simple language
um to communicate clearly rather than
trying to sort of signal sophistication
or anything like that and when you can
communicate clearly
um then you naturally become smarter
because your your thoughts and your you
know what what you write reflect each
other so if you think clearly you're
right clearly and if you're right
clearly You'll Think Clearly
um you know if you try to think in these
big long words that you barely
understand you're not going to really
develop a good understanding of of what
you're actually thinking have you heard
so this is one example
have you heard the mental model never
multiply by zero
I think I have but I can't recall what
it is you might have to remind me yeah
so it ties in it ties into this
perfectly so never multiply by zero
describes avoiding situations that could
permanently get you out of the game
whatever that game may be so for
instance you could have the perfect
health and fitness regime making sure
that you eat organic fruit and
vegetables your micros and macros are
perfect you sleep eight hours every
night and you're hydrated thoroughly
throughout the day but you have a common
habit of driving a car without the seat
belt it's like okay all of the good
things that you're doing it's 45 times 7
times 1.2 times 360 times zero if you
multiply any sequence of numbers by zero
the outcome is zero it's the same as
you've been saving for a long time and
working hard on your education and you
can't wait to move away but you commonly
have unprotected sex and accidentally
get pregnant
okay that has put a very big change that
has stopped a lot of the things that you
had intended and it's the same here it
is it is remarkable how much long-term
Advantage People Like Us have gotten by
trying to be consistently not stupid
instead of trying to be very intelligent
you can get so much success in life
simply by avoiding failure because so
many people multiply either by zero or
by a half or by three quarters and it
takes down so much of the good work that
they've done
yeah absolutely yeah
um it's it's the lowest common
denominator issue isn't it it's people
can focus all of their energies on
certain things
and maximize those you know until their
heart's content but they'll neglect one
tiny aspect of their life and then that
will be the thing that brings them down
and um I think when you when you're
trying to be smart you can get lost in
trying to excel at one particular thing
whilst neglecting all of the other
things that are periphery but which are
just just as important all of the
supporting things I I've found just it
simplifies life so much when you just
try not to be stupid you know it just
it's just such a more elegant and simple
way to live than to try to be smart I
don't have any I you know I used to
Signal a lot to people you know
especially on social media and stuff
where I used to try to just be as smart
as I possibly could
but it will often just lead me into just
complete stupidity because I would just
be hyper focused on one thing trying to
make that thing as perfect as possible
and in so do we God neglect everything
else which was needed so yeah I mean
it's all about being a generalist it's
not about being a specialist anymore you
know if you want to excel in life now
you've got to be a generalist you've got
to be good at you've got to have a
Baseline
sort of goodness at everything rather
than you know being super good at one
thing because that super goodness that
one thing can lead you astray
interesting okay next one Cunningham's
law the best way to get the right answer
on the internet is not to ask a question
but to post the wrong answer because
people are more interested in
criticizing others than helping them
this is so incisive it's so correct
yeah yeah I mean it's the
the actual I mean Connor's law is
basically just um the best way to get
the right answer on the internet is not
to ask a question but post the answer
and then I was the one who who basically
decided that it was because people are
more interested in criticizing others
than helping them so I don't want to um
give the impression that you know if
just in case this turns out to be wrong
that that was the law his law is just
the first part of that
um
so I mean yeah I've witnessed this
constantly since I've been on social
media you know places like Twitter and
Reddit
I even I think I even did this
experiment myself where I actually asked
a question and I got very little
response and then I deliberately posted
the the wrong answer I'm pretty sure I
did that once earlier in 2016 or
something like that because this is
something that I've thought about for a
long time and um I think
many people are constantly on the
lookout for someone to ridicule and I
think
they they want that because they want to
feel better about themselves so if if
you give people an opportunity to
make them look smarter than you they
will take it you know because people
want validation on social media and one
of the ways people get validation is by
pointing out when other people get
things wrong
um I mean I used to do this a lot as
well I used to I used to re I mean I
don't know if I was trying to seek
validation maybe I was subconsciously
but I did get this drive to really point
out when people got things wrong and I
felt like a duty almost to do it I don't
do it anymore but I used to always do on
social media if I saw something that was
incorrect
stand on the shoulders of somebody
else's stupidity right so by pointing at
the stupidity really interesting thing
so I'm
I'm all for
um calling out the performative
incentives of social media but Chris
Voss the guy that wrote Never split the
difference he was the former head of the
FBI's negotiation team he said that one
of the ways that he extracts information
from people who are either unwitting or
unwilling is he will
uh make proposals about them that are
wrong but that they want to correct so
for instance he'll say that's a that's a
great accent is that uh that's Hull
isn't it that's you're from Hull no no
I'm actually from Huddersfield you go oh
yeah interesting but you I mean you must
be a Pisces I actually am an Aquarius
and you go okay I've got the place that
you live and the month of your birth
that simply by proposing things that are
wrong and I it's I don't know where it
comes from it can't just be performative
fanciness on the Internet it's something
deeper than that it's a desire to close
Loops of erroneous information and I
think that that just gets maybe
magnified when the internet's involved
yeah yeah I think
I think that probably is part of it
people probably do it for different
reasons I mean this is quite it's quite
a general sort of concept so I mean you
know I'm sure it's not just a specific
it has one specific cause
um but yeah I mean I think it's always
better you get a lot more information
out of people by getting them to tell
you what they want to tell you rather
than trying to sort of railroad them
into an answer you know so I think a lot
of sort of
interrogators would probably do that I
don't know I don't know their tactics
but I could see them doing that
um you know they would rather rather
than actually asking you a question they
would give you a statement that would
lead you to a certain response I think
because then you don't feel like you're
being interrogated as well you know you
feel like you're just giving the
information freely which probably is
better for them
um you know so I don't know but I'm not
an experience so I don't know next one
wittgenstein's ruler the less you know
of the measurer compared to the thing
being measured the less the measurer's
measure measures the thing being
measured and the more it measures the
measurer as an analogy if a man says
everyone he meets is an [__] the
[__] is likely him you can apply this
concept to any source of information for
example if a news Outlet stories
frequently outrage you instead of taking
it as evidence that the world is
becoming more outrageous consider the
possibility that the news Outlet is
deliberately trying to outrage you and
temper your reactions accordingly
basically never take information at face
value and always ask yourself what does
the info from this Source suggest about
the source itself
yeah so I'll never sort of understand
why people just take information at face
value you know I see it just constantly
online where somebody will say something
and then nobody questions the motives
behind the person saying it they just
it's as though it's like chat GPT saying
it to them you know they'll just accept
whatever it is is being said without any
kind of uh suspicion towards the motives
behind why did somebody say this you
know what does this say about the source
of the information
um I think it's just a very very
important skill for media literacy
in the age of misinformation
there's you know there's there's always
an agenda behind every piece of
information that is shown on your screen
um apart from in the cases of Chachi PT
but but that's a different issue but
like when you're getting information
from other human beings there's always
an agenda there there's always some
reason why you're being showed that
information some reason why they've
chosen to disclose that information
and I think it's always worth
considering
what those potential agendas could be
because that is half of the information
you're being given
you know if you're just accepting the
information at face value you're only
receiving half of the information
uh you need you need the other half you
need the half the context
you know so
um you see this you know if for instance
like the guardian uh posts something
about
um
the economy you know and then you see
that the author and then you can do a
bit of background research into that
person's views on economics and then
it's amazing how much information that
will provide you when you actually read
the article oh so that is then you'll
suddenly yeah that would be the first
line of wittgenstein's ruler is the less
you know of the measurer so what you're
doing there is you're learning more
about the measurer
yeah yeah you want to get as much as
much information about both sources you
want to get sorry not bad sources about
the the source and the information so
you want to get as much information
about both and you should the ruler in
this case is the one that you have the
most information about so if you have
more information about the information
then the source then you should use the
information to measure the source and if
you have more information about the
source you should use source to measure
the information so it's you know it's
basically like you would
if you had two rulers and you weren't
sure which one was crazy you knew one of
them was correct and the other one
wasn't you would use the correct one to
measure the one that wasn't you know so
it's a similar principle interesting
okay Purity spiral members of political
tribes inevitably begin competing with
their fellows to be the most
ideologically pure the constant
one-upmanship toward moral superiority
causes the whole group to gradually
become more extreme for example maoist
China or Twitter Echo Chambers nice that
you drew the correlation between those
two there
this is good yeah
I think people have this kind of
tendency to turn everything into a
competition
and that goes for Morality also you know
if you have
a certain
dominant ideology dominant moral
ideology
uh that's fashionable again going back
to the thing that we talked about before
then people will start competing they'll
turn into a competition and start
gamifying it essentially the adult turn
it into an opportunity to
um
to sort of gain an advantage of social
advantage
uh and this has been shown throughout
history I mean you know it's not just
Mao is China you can look at any regime
that had strong sort of laws uh against
certain behaviors or in favor of certain
behaviors and you would see that there
were people always who would compete to
either haul out those behaviors in other
people or if they were bad or engage in
those behaviors if they were good
you know literally any any regime you
name you know you you'll see you can see
examples of it it's it's something
that's sort of fundamental to our
species
and it's one of the reasons why I think
a lot of
regimes become
uh more extreme over time you know a lot
of them like for instance if you look at
if we go and buy this sort of uh the
example of communism
uh you know Lenin was pretty bad he was
quite bad he wasn't Stalin though you
know Stalin was a completely different
category of sort of authoritarian and it
would have continued as long as Stalin
was there because he got worse and worse
as as he gave more and more power it
wasn't just because he was getting more
power it was because the people around
him were also becoming more extreme if
you have a look at people like laurenti
barrier for instance you know they were
also they became more extreme over time
and
part of it was because I think of the
Purity spiral where people felt that
they had to uh compete to be as much
like Stalin as possible in order to
avoid being purged
um so in this case it was literally a
life or death matter but it's not always
a life of death matter sometimes it's
just a case of status which is more the
case on Twitter
did you ever hear Tim Dillon push back
on Joe Rogan's view of La comedy
because this is exactly the same thing
so uh Tim's one of the few guys that can
kind of poke back at Joe because he's
you know similar status and he's he's
doing well in comedy scene and stuff
like that
and Joe was saying about how lovely the
LA comedy scene is you know every time
that he goes through there everything's
just fantastic and everyone treats him
so well and Tim sort of bumped in and
said Joe you do know that you're Joe
Rogan right that the way that people
behave when you step into the room is
not representative of how they behave
typically for other people that there is
a reality Distortion field that occurs
when this happens and because of that
your experience may not be
representative of everybody else's I
can't remember the rule that we went
through but this was one one of the
previous episodes that you featured on
where uh as somebody gains power the
people around them are more concerned
with appeasing the person in power than
giving them real information from the
world outside so if you have Purity
syndrome yeah Howard Hughes syndrome
thank you that's it
um so if you combine Howard Hughes
syndrome with the Purity spiral the
Purity spiral is the incentive or the
Purity spiral is like the the drive and
the direction that that's the what's
going on and then the Howard Hughes
syndrome is the fuel that persists and
causes that to keep on going uh one one
question I've got in my mind is what
sort of environment
would
engender a more Purity spiral-like
situation what are some of the
predictors of a purity spiral do you
think
so they need to be rewards incentives
basically for that kind of behavior they
need to be rewards for extreme Behavior
so
um you know if you if you look at say
Twitter for instance there are rewards
to acting if you're you know if you're
like in right-wing circles for instance
then there's an incentive to act based
you know and if you're in the left-wing
circles and there's an incentive to act
woke because
other people will see you as a sort of
paragon of what they believe and then
they'll they'll want to retweet you and
you know say oh this person if you're
based for instance people say this
person doesn't give a [__] you know he's
you know basically he's sticking it to
the lips you know he's triggering the
lips or whatever
um and you know vice versa with the with
the left they'll be like you know this
person is calling it out like calling
out Injustice or whatever blah blah so
there's got to be some sort of
um social reward for uh engaging in more
extreme Behavior than your peers uh
that's the first rule and another thing
is this is probably an even better
incentive would be that um
if if there's a punishment for not
acting more extreme and this is more to
do with the sort of stalinist kind of
element of things so if you look at the
purges for instance in fact there's an
even better example than that
um if you look at there's a very famous
video of Saddam Hussein where he
basically is in a room filled with
people and um
he basically says that he's uncovered a
plot this was shortly after he assumed
power it was shortly after he assumed
control in Iraq and the way that he
consolidates power was that he basically
concocted this idea that there was a
conspiracy against him so that he could
you know pre-text to remove people that
he didn't like and he had a list of
names and he said that these people had
betrayed him and there was a big packed
room filled with people all of the sort
of delegates and diplomats and one by
one he called out the names of the
betrayers and they were LED out of the
room to their deaths they were basically
executed and as soon as people realized
what was happening they began to panic
and they began to copy Saddam Hussein's
actions so there's a point where he um
he he was apparently crying or he was
pretending to cry and he got a
handkerchief and he began to wipe his
eyes and immediately the camera pans to
the the crowd to the audience and you
see many like people just get
handicachieves out of their hands and
sort of out of the pockets and they
begin to um wipe their own eyes exactly
how Salim says doing and it's I think
it's a sort of it speaks to sort of this
idea that people were so terrified of
dying that they just the only they
panicked and the only thing that they
knew how to do to prevent from dying is
to be as as much like Saddam as possible
I imagine one other predictor or another
predictor
of the Purity spiral would be an
important in-group out group
uh tribal Dynamic that's happening
because the whole purpose of having a
purity spiral is to identify others
right there is us and there is not us
and if you do not do the things pray do
the shibboleths ETC that is the us then
you're anatas and it's why
intersectionality in particular is a
pretty obvious example of what goes on
with regards to a purity spiral because
in part some of it is based on fanciful
exaggerations and also it's mostly based
on not being another as opposed to being
a something when you have a poorly
defined something the only way you can
identify yourself is as not being the
other and what that means is in order to
keep group cohesion together you need to
constantly shave off people who are
others it's like if your mutual love of
an in-group is not bound together over
that it's bound together of the mutual
hatred of an out group you need to
permanently find new out group members
in order to say well see we're not we're
not that for instance Douglas Murray uh
gay man but like white and conservative
so he's not really a part of the LGBT
movement anymore you know like you're
just gay it's like dude you really need
to be like gay and black with a club
foot and a gluten intolerance like
that's really where you need to be at in
order to be a part of our club
yeah absolutely um it's easier to Rally
around shared hatreds than shared values
and so there are people always looking
to create new things to hate just in
order to keep the group together
um you know share values are are okay
for a while but really what people want
is they want to get together to really
hate somebody you know there's a few
things that bring people together like
hating someone else and I think a lot of
this happens like I mean you see it in
um
when uh there's this thing called rally
around the flag syndrome which is a
concept another one of my mega thread
Concepts where it's this idea that when
uh leaders are unpopular
with the public what they do is they
will start conflicts they'll start
foreign conflicts uh because this will
bring people together against the mutual
enemy and I mean some people have argued
that that Putin part of the reason that
Putin invaded Ukraine was that he was
flagging in popularity and people were
becoming disillusioned with them and so
he needed to have a sort of external
enemy to sort of unite the people and
sort of you know create this this other
that they could sort of level all their
hatred against you see it in the novel
Animal Farm as well where um the
character of uh Napoleon the pig
Napoleon um wants to consolidate his
power by sort of
um essentially exiling snowball who's
his rival and then just sort of blaming
him for literally everything that's
going wrong you know scapegoating and
that's how the sort of Animal Farm gets
Consolidated and how they form their
sort of their their Community by hate
hatred rather than love
this is one of mine so I've got a new
one for you here and this is Schultz's
razor do not attribute to group
conspiracy that which can be explained
by cancellation anxiety from the outside
it might look like everyone is
coordinating to push some ideology or
movement from the inside everyone is
terrified of losing their job if they
don't adhere to the new ideological
stance it's not coordination it's
cowardice a lot of the time we believe
that there is a grand plan at work to
try and push a narrative or hurt people
from a particular group from the outside
it looks a lot like a coordinated
assault collusion orchestrated some by
some malign Overlord conspiracy but on
the ground it doesn't look anything like
that it's just individuals trying to
save their own skin and not get fired
they've got an expensive house they can
barely pay the mortgage on and a wife
who wants a new car and private school
for kids it's much easier for them to
adhere to whatever ideology will keep
them in their job rather than go against
it sure it might mean that they push an
unhinged story about trans Story Hour
for toddlers or ban someone from saying
something innocuous on a platform but
this doesn't mean that they've been
indoctrine in some grand plan the
incentives encourage execs influential
actors and people in power to behave in
particular aligned ways but their
coordination is not consciously
conducted it's just a path of least
resistance for each person it doesn't
make them less culpable it makes them
less malicious and more cowardly for
sure and Schultz finish this off and
said so much content is curated by a
pool getting installed in an executive's
yard
yeah that's a fair assessment I think
it's quite accurate
um it sounds to me like sort of
handling's Razor
um uh sort of applied to council culture
I think yeah a lot of people
are more passive than active when it
comes to
um the sort of propagation of new
ideologies and I see this pretty much
all the time
um
you know if we go back to the example of
workers and stuff like that
is largely pushed not by idiolocs not by
people who are you know actively trying
to sort of spread this ideology but
mostly by people who just sort of read
Wikipedia
to see what ideas are on there and just
accept them as fact and just think okay
I better not question this because you
know this is the consensus amongst my
community and you know if I if I speak
out against this I I'm going to be in
trouble so I'll just keep my mouth shut
and that's largely how you know these
ideologies really spread I think
um it's it's sort of like it goes back
to the sort of chilling effect where
people are afraid of saying what they
really think so they just keep their
mouths shut and then this allows false
ideas to propagate uh much more quickly
um so yeah I mean I I think that's it's
a pretty straightforward
um one is this you said it was Schultz's
razor who who was the one who who so the
Andrew Schultz on on on his podcast just
talked about the fact that
um he's spent time in Hollywood in
Hollywood everyone from the outside
thinks that it's all of these people
trying to trans the kids and stuff and
he said from the inside there's none of
that you know they're blundering around
just trying to sort themselves out and
get to CrossFit in time yeah and it just
I I came up with Schultz's razor and
then sent it to him and asked if I've
got uh if he reckons that it was a good
summation of what he was talking about
and he was like [__] hell that's
really nice do not attribute to groups
conspiracy that which can be explained
by cancellation anxiety but another
thing the reason that I really like it
and I actually spoke about this in Miami
this weekend I spoke about that exact
passage is because it's very reassuring
for the people who are concerned that we
are facing an insurmountable coordinated
coalitional assault right on our
freedoms because what it reminds you is
it individual actors incentives can
align in such a way to make it look like
collusion but it's not and if it's not
it's actually a lot more fractured and
fragile and all that you need to do to
fix something which isn't a coordinated
conspiracy is change the incentives if
the incentives then change that
immediately opens up and frees pretty
much everything else
yeah I think there's that famous quote
which is the only thing necessary for
the Triumph of evil and is for good men
to do nothing um which I think really
sort of sums it up
I think yeah I agree I agree I don't
think that there is some sort of massive
conspiracy to trans people or anything
like that you know I think that's just
nonsense
um I but I mean
what I am worried about is exactly what
you've just been saying which is that
there are going to be a lot of people
who simply will just accept stuff that
that is probably and true
simply because they're afraid and you
know I don't have specific concerns
about trans the trans sort of ideology
in particular but just generally I think
this is a danger
um for pretty much any anything really I
mean you know you've got the equivalent
conspiracy theories on the right
about the world economic Forum so many
people believe in this now they believe
that there's some evil Destiny plot by
the Wes to sort of enslave everybody and
I mean I've looked at the evidence and
I'm not convinced by it I could be wrong
but I think people are just sort of most
people are just sort of accepting it on
the right now just as people are
accepting accepting sort of a lot of
ideas work ideas on the left you've now
got people accepting conspiracy theories
on the right just because everybody else
is accepting them and I think that's
quite dangerous what was that
um
the world has many stupid people and few
evil people therefore the world's few
evil people have experience stupidity
bonhoeffer's theory yes yes I mean
that's the same as this right that's
that's precisely yeah yeah that you have
and it would be maybe not stupid people
uh but just self-interested people or uh
you know resourcefully anxious people
yeah yeah passive I would say I just say
passive people because I think you know
like you alluded to earlier they're more
interested in feeding their families and
who can blame them you know
um they want to feed their families they
want to
um just live their lives you know I mean
why would you know why worry about all
these things that are probably not going
to influence
Our Lives sort of very much unless
there's some drastic you know uh sort of
uh tyranny that just suddenly takes over
but that's very unlikely I mean I think
most of these issues things like um
the whole thing about the trans ideology
and the WF EF and all these other you
know sort of theories
They Don't Really impact the average
person uh very much in their lives these
are really social media issues these are
issues that people get really really
worked to put over social media and this
is not to say that there's no real world
impact there is obviously but the the
level at which they're being discussed
is far in excess of their actual real
world impact there's far more important
things to be worrying about you know
like AI for instance
um you know AI is a major major issue
now but most people are still worried
about trans people in toilets and it's
um you know that like AI is literally an
existential threat I mean not in the
immediate future but eventually it will
be uh you know once we've got AI now
that will soon give rise to AGI AGI will
probably give rise to a super
intelligence
um
yeah I mean unless it's long term I mean
there's short-term issues with AI which
are even more dangerous possibly which
um you know the idea of sort of
misinformation now is it can be done on
an industrial scale you can literally
just fill the web up with misinformation
without any real human labor yeah I mean
think about if if you were concerned
what six years ago with Cambridge
analytica is that one that came out six
or seven years ago yeah it was about six
years ago I think yeah if you're worried
about Cambridge analytica
um having a team of copywriters create
ads and then use
rudimentary algorithmic analysis to
Target those to people that they think
it'll impact the most imagine having a
virtual Avatar that reflects every
social media user's preferences that
exists on the internet and have them be
able to create the perfectly persuasive
individually tailored message to nudge
your preferences over time that it can
account for neuro-linguistic programming
it can have controlled opposition that
shows you the other side you know I mean
it's I think both of us are of the
opinion that within the next five years
or so almost all of the content that is
produced on social media won't be
produced by humans I spoke to uh uh Rob
wibleen the guy that does 80 000 hours
he's big in the effective altruism
community and long-termism and
existential risk he as a career
podcaster like myself says that within
10 years he thinks that AI will do his
job better than he ever can so he's
already looking to wind down into
retirement from podcasting podcasting
was one of the few things where I
considered that it might be a little bit
more
safe given that people don't tune in for
the rote indexing of information but
they tune in more for the natural human
Vibe which is inherently difficult to
predict like the way that language
learning models work is it's essentially
predictive text just replicated over
time all the way so by Design it's a
very predictive form of communication an
unpredictive form which is where you
might actually uh find something
Charming or endearing or funny or
whatever uh come it is significantly
more complex computationally
absolutely yeah um I think the the sort
of that that really does touch on
something very important there I think
where you just said
um there is a certain Randomness to
human behavior which is inherently
valuable I think which people value more
than
um sort of the Perfection the so-called
Perfection of things that are
artificially created
um and you can see this I mean there's
actually there are um apps now which can
actually which purport to be able to
determine whether a piece of text was
written by an AI or by a human they use
a measure called perplexity which is
exactly what you were just saying a
measure of the randomness of the of text
or whether it's representative I think
probably averageness is a better term
for it it's basically how how
um indicative of
the training data a piece of text is
um so
complexity is actually turned out to be
a really really bad way of determining
whether something was written by an AI
or a human and I use this myself I got
an essay that I wrote in 2017 and I fed
it into this machine this device which
basically is supposed to determine
whether I'm a human or AI and it accused
me of being an AI I knew I [__] knew
it I [__] knew it all along bastard
yeah yeah the bastard I mean I couldn't
believe it I thought you know okay fair
enough I'll do it again and I did it a
few times and I think once or twice it
got it correct it managed to identify me
as a human but most of the time it was
calling me an AI right and that's
because um I was writing in a style
which was very indicative of Journalism
back in 2017 because I was I was writing
for a magazine called rabbit hole and
they had a very strict editorial style
and so I was writing um I was writing
sentences sort of very clean I wasn't
adding much of my own character to the
sentences
exactly and that's why it came to that
conclusion but it shows that really you
know
um
it's very uh I think what people really
want is is they want a bit of flair I
think to writing they don't want um just
the information just to be given to them
they want the information to be given to
them with a bit of flair and I think you
see that not just in in writing but you
see it in in a lot of Industries I mean
for instance people like flaws they like
the human flaws that only a human has
um because that gives things character
for instance if you look at a diamond
uh you have synthetic diamonds now which
are far more
um
perfect and Flawless than real diamonds
that are sort of mined and yet mine
diamonds are far more valuable they self
are just far more money and I think part
of that is because the floors are
actually what make it valuable the fact
not just flaws but also the fact that it
was dug out of the Earth by a human and
it has a story behind it you know I
think that story The the history of that
thing is is what gives it value people
call it people in the art World call it
provenance and that's one of the things
that gives human made things value is
that they have a story behind them
um you know if you have something that's
just sterile and perfect and you know
just clear and has no idiosyncrasies yep
it kind of diminishes the value of it
even though it's it's perfect on a
technical level it's not it doesn't have
a story
right it's very sterile to do it that
way this is what I tell fledgling
podcasters that ask for advice is your
job is not to perfectly index all of the
information in yours or the guest's head
and that forgetting that town that's on
the west coast of the the north of
England that's what's it called it's
near Manchester Blackpool like that's
that is part of the vibe it is adding to
the character of you as a person and
there are podcasters out there that
spend a lot of money on editors to go
through and remove any heavy breaths or
pauses or mistakes by them or the guests
or whatever and I mean if you want that
you can go to blinkist as far as I'm
concerned it's the job is to ask
questions that are outside of the scope
of the book that are unique that you
can't get elsewhere and also to create a
Vibe you know if you and your friend
can't breathe because you're laughing
for 20 seconds that's part of you and
it speaks massively I think as well an
over-reliance on that whether it be
online with writing or in podcasting or
on YouTube or whatever it speaks
massively to an insecurity that you are
not worthy of acceptance or that your
work or you as a person is not going to
be enjoyed by the audience and I
understand that I understand why in a
presentation you might want to overthink
and so on and so forth but being able to
let go and again this is only something
that you can achieve through many
repetitions of doing anything of this
kind but you must have found this with
writing that as you get out of your own
way more and just say look I'm gonna
avoid being stupid I'm gonna say things
as clearly and precisely and simply as I
can and I'm going to have faith that the
accumulated experience I've got is going
to make something good and then once
it's out there it's fine but when you
start to overthink it when you've spent
six months planning what it's going to
be and you've built it up and it's this
big Behemoth and then
oh everything's tight and and awkward
and uncomfortable so anyway next one
next one it's a really good one uh post
journalism the Press lost its Monopoly
on news when the internet democratized
info to save its business model
inhibited from journalism into tribalism
the new role of the press is not to
inform its readers but to confirm what
they already believe
post-journalism
yeah so
there was a study um published in the
social science computer review
um and basically what it was a team of
researchers analyzed 27 million news
articles published between 1970 and
2019. and what they found was that use
of words like sexist and racist in the
New York Times and in The Wider liberal
media increased over 400 percent since
2012.
so obviously sexism and racism have not
actually increased 400 since 2012. it's
only the media's use of these terms
that's increased and this they found
this was the case anyway you know they
found that essentially what happened was
that there was some event that had
occurred that had caused a massive shift
in the editorial policy of the New York
Times towards sex and race and I mean
this was actually a I think who was it
there was a writer who who dubbed this
the Great Awakening uh he although he
didn't he didn't refer to this specific
example but he referred to a general
Trend that that occurred with the rise
of social media in the early 2010s where
there was this sudden shift towards the
issues of sex and race and this was
driven by the media I think I think this
was driven by the fact that this the New
York Times was no longer the sole author
you know one of the sole authorities of
news anymore um with the sort of Advent
of social media and and all this
alternative media that sprang up and
stuff like The Joe Rogan podcast and all
these alternative sources of information
the New York Times had suddenly lost its
Authority um it was no longer it no
longer had a monopoly on information and
so obviously they had to do something
and I believe I don't have any hard
evidence of it but I think that this is
what led to this surge in usage of um
terms like sex is reason and the rise of
the sort of you know woke politics in
media because I feel that
it it decided that it was going to cater
to hipsters basically you know to
certain I don't want to stereotype them
too much but the kinds of people who
hang out in Starbucks and you know like
um you know drinks sort of pumpkin spicy
lattes and all that you know they wanted
to sort of they thought the music will
be coming for you hard
yeah yeah I was trying to they're
actually quite nice I've drank drank a
few myself
I did it before everybody else
that's the most hipster thing you could
say that doesn't defend you from being a
hipster yeah okay so what you're saying
is that uh the the New York Times they
need to uh they need to re-engineer news
from being something which accurately
portrays what's going on to competing
for clicks up against people who are
significantly better at getting clicks
um what it seems like if uh racism and
sexism have increased by 400 since 2012
in New York Times in the liberal media
it seems like
racism and sexism
have been split tested as the most
limbically hijacking perfectly curated
tempting way to get people to press on a
news article
yeah absolutely yeah because the
interesting thing with these uh terms is
that they don't just get the audience uh
from the new they don't just get the
liberal audience engaged they also get
conservative audience engaged because
you know the conservative sort of uh
media ecosystem is largely reactive
which fits in with their reactionary
ideology so they they react to the
liberal politics of the day to the
liberal mainstream media and so when the
New York Times
um says that air conditioning is racist
or whatever
then Fox News is going to come out
Tucker Carlson is going to go on and
he's going to say you know look at this
madness in the New York Times you know
the world's going to hell the New York
Times now is claiming that conditioning
is racist and the New York Times
Obviously knows that Tucker Carlson is
going to do this and that's why they do
it because they know that they can
provoke him so then Tucker gets his
audience of uh conservatives to
essentially just take part in this
dialogue to take part in this sort of
debate and that drives more traffic to
the New York Times uh when people share
it like look at this craziness you know
on social media what they're doing
they're doing the New York times's own
work for them you know they're just
sharing it even it doesn't matter if uh
people don't like the New York Times
article it's still getting shared and
that's what matters at the end of the
day people are clicking on it so that
they can hate it and I think you know
that's really the sort of the liberal
media's business model and the
Conservative media's Business model the
liberal media will randomly accuse
things of being sexist or racist knowing
that it's going to fire a lot of people
then the right-wing media the
conservative media will sort of react
just as predicted and it will just
create it's like a sort of symbiosis
where they sort of fuel each other you
know they fuel each other's traffic and
uh you know I mean
you do see it happening the other way
now as well you see you know Tucker
Carlson or whatever will make a claim
which is absolutely crazy on Fox News
and then the New York Times will write
an opinion piece about him and how his
danger to you know everyone and he's
gonna you know create the Third Reich or
whatever like um sorry the fourth Reich
but like um you know it's uh
it's back and forth between them they
have this
this sort of tribal Warfare thing going
on and they both they both monetized it
they're both profit from it and
everybody else loses because everybody
else becomes more stupid as a result
and then that's basically the media
ecosystem now I think
there's a really good quote from Dana
White and this is from three years ago
now and he says the media are not in the
news business they are in the clickbait
business they think negativity sells and
gets clicks so that's what they deliver
negativity is their product and what
he's touching on there is the fact that
people are more likely to click on
sensationalist negative stories than
they are I mean dude we see this even
when it comes to designing thumbnails
for the channel if I use a term like war
or battle uh go to war with your mind
you must battle for self-improvement
stuff like that even though they're
being used in a positive manner it's
still an inflammatory word and it gets
more clicks you know people people see
that wall that words they see the word
war and they go oh what are you gonna
click on it even if it is a a war for
more [__] hypertrophy or whatever it
is anyway next one uh noble cause
corruption the greatest evils come not
from those seeking to do bad but from
those seeking to do good and believing
the ends justify the means ironically
few things justify the immoral treatment
of others more than the belief that
you're more moral than them
yeah so
if you look at sort of people
who do evil things in life very few of
them are actually evil in terms of very
few of them actually set out to
deliberately do evil uh you know I mean
there are probably a handful of serial
killers who would fall under this
umbrella people like Richard Ramirez you
know the Night Stalker I would say he
was probably
closest you could come to somebody who
was just doing things purely because
they were evil he deliberately went out
to do things because he knew that they
were evil
but people like that are extremely rare
in life and the vast majority of of sort
of evil acts in life are committed by
people who actually think they're doing
good if you look at history you know I
mean how many people have
created atrocities as a result of them
trying to be evil trying to do the wrong
thing uh not I don't know of any but
then if you ask yourself how many people
have committed atrocities in the name of
trying to do good
well you could you can there's no end of
them you know they're just everywhere
like her
if you know if you look at the classic
example I mean even people like Hitler I
mean Hitler's regarded as a classic
super villain
um but the fact of the matter is is that
he wasn't he wasn't evil in the sense
that he didn't deliberately set out to
do evil he actually believed he was
doing the right thing you know and and
Germany believed he was doing the right
thing as well that's why they elected
him uh you know he wasn't he didn't just
take over power and become a tyrant and
go against the German people's Wishes
the German people elected him into power
and they elected him because they
believed in his message because they
believed he was correct that
Western Germanic civilization was
collapsing and uh it was the fault of
Jews and Gypsies and Jehovah's Witnesses
uh because they were apparently stealing
the wealth of the country and they were
erupting the minds of the the youth with
degenerate art as they as the Nazis
called it so these ideas were very
common they were not just common in
Germany they were common in the US
they've common in Europe
um anti-Semitism was was commonplace in
the 1920s and 30s I mean you know there
was a in Madison Square Garden there was
a massive meeting of American Nazis now
can you imagine that today imagine today
you had like uh you know
um Nazi Fest 2023 yeah exactly hiring at
Madison Square Garden you know and
actually having a live show Neo-Nazi
show and that's what it was like in
1920s so there was a lot of people who
actually believed that it was right to
do what that what Hitler eventually did
um you know which is actually terrifying
when you think about it this wasn't this
wasn't just some madman who just told
took over power and then decided to
exterminate an invite you know entire
race of people this was something that
had support from the bottom from the
Grassroots
and so these people were convinced they
were doing the right thing
it says here
ironically a few things justify the
immoral treatment of others more than
the belief that you're more moral than
them what does the more moral than them
part have to play here
so
if you think if we go back to the
example of of Jews in Germany uh Nazi
Germany uh
Hitler and the Nazis believed that they
were morally superior to the Jews
because they believe that the Jews were
corrupting people
um because they believed by the first
they believed that they were greedy and
they were stealing the wealth of Germany
secondly they believed that they were
corrupting uh the minds of Germanic
youth um by with the with their
so-called degenerate art
um they were essentially undermining
civilization they were parasites that
were destroying civilization so they
were immoral in that sense that's that's
what the Nazis believed and so the Nazis
believed that since these people are not
moral people they're not ethical since
the Jews are not ethical people in their
View it's okay to exterminate them it's
okay they're not human they're subhumans
you know they're undimension uh wiping
them out is good for society and you see
this literally in every other example of
this kind so if you go to the polar
opposite example of Stalin
um Stalin believed that the bourgeoisie
were morally inferior to the
proletarians because they were they had
been corrupted by their wealth uh they
were greedy they were you know
capitalist they wanted to enslave
uh everybody else and so he used this
idea that that the humble worker was
more uh moral and more ethical than the
bourgeoisie to um to sort of justify the
murder of the bourgeoisie and not just
the bourgeoisie but pretty much anybody
who spoke out against him so these
people were by definition
because they were obstacles to the
Utopia that he was trying to enact so
the idea is that if you know if you can
present yourself as more moral than your
enemies then you can justify their
Slaughter because nobody's gonna miss
um a person you know who's who's immoral
I mean I'd like to think about
a very commonplace example would be um
the the idea of card molesters like
child molesters are considered probably
the most evil uh and the people the most
least worthy of sympathy people on the
planet and I know people who are really
really good high people like really nice
kind compassionate people and I hear
them sometimes say things like I mean
there's one person that I know who's
really really kind person really a
passionate person and they said that
what they wanted was um for child
molesters to be locked in a room
with a ground with with floor made out
of sandpaper that was basically a
treadmill that never ended
you know that's what they wanted and
they said it they said it without any
money they just said that that's what
they should do to to child nurses and
this is a classic example like if
somebody is regarded as morally inferior
then they they lose any right to
compassion in an average person's mind
like you can you know you can say oh
this person's child must say you can do
whatever you like to them because
they're not human because of what
they've done and so if you can present a
person as morally defective as a morally
inferior then you don't feel bad no
matter what happens to them and that's
why you know people who are so convinced
of their own morality when they see
somebody who's less moral than them or
who they think is less more than them
then they can become complete monsters
towards that person
so that's where I think a lot of the
world's greatest atrocities occur is due
to that that sort of belief
fascinating okay next one gwynda's third
Paradox in order for you to beat someone
in a debate your opponent needs to
realize they've lost therefore it's
easier to win an argument against a
genius than an idiot
this is the reason I stopped debating
you know I I well it's one of the
reasons anyway I I used to debate people
all the time on social media you know I
used to I used to think it was something
worth doing I just thought you know that
I could convince people but I realized
um after a while that really a debate is
not it's not it's not really a battle of
intellect it's not a match of wits
uh it's really just
uh it's a more of a battle of ego
than intellect because people want to
win they don't want to understand
and they approach their they approach
debates
there's a rationalist thinker called
Julia gallif who had this great book
called
um Scout mindset she came on she
basically
yeah yeah great yeah yeah in fact I
think I saw that one yeah and um yeah
she yeah she made the case that
basically when people
um
when they enter the base they tend to
approach with the soldier mindset which
is that they just want to win they just
want to conquer the enemy they have no
real other goal but they should really
approach with a scout mindset which is
to seek as much information as possible
uh to objective information do what
Scout does rather than what soldier does
but the problem is is that most people
are sold they approach with the soldier
mindset and
when you approach with a soldier mindset
and you're not very bright
what will happen is you'll often just
keep going because your ego is just
driving you you know further and further
and you won't see that you're you've
actually lost in the debate because your
ego is just there and you just you're
trying to do everything you can you're
moving the goal posts you know as much
as you can to try to win at all costs I
think with smarter people this is not
say that smart people don't approach
they also can be extremely
um egotistical and they can be arrogance
but they often are more likely to
realize when they've screwed up when
they've contradicted themselves or when
they've uh you know they've said
something that's just factually
Incorrect and it's harder for them to
come back
from that because they realize they've
screwed up you know so they're like oh
okay and they can't just pretend they
can't just you know yeah some of them
will but
he says that um once you've become
convinced of something even if you claim
the opposite you can no longer
unconvince yourself of it if I convince
you that it's two equals four and you
then see it you can tell me no no it's
three I know it's three but on the
inside you you can't become an up until
a point at which somebody convinces you
of something else you can't be
unconvinced of something which you are
convinced of but as you've spoken about
in your most recent sub stack article
that everybody needs to go and read
smart people plus ideology is a
tariffing terrifying cocktail because
that can use their Ingenuity to engineer
a more easily a more uh fortified
defense around their irrational beliefs
or around just beliefs that they haven't
assessed so there's a another thing that
relates to this so gwynda's third
Paradox about needing to ensure that
your opponent has to work out that
they've lost this is from Scott
Alexander and it's years ago this is
from his old stuff if you're interested
in being on the right side of disputes
you will refute your opponent's
arguments but if you're interested in
producing truth you will fix your
opponent's Arguments for them to win you
must fight not only the creature you
encounter you must fight the most
horrible thing that be king that can be
constructed from its corpse
it's a very good way of putting it yeah
um there's a concept called rogerian
rhetoric which is how I try to approach
uh any kind of discussion which is
instead of trying to convince that
person that they're wrong what I try to
do is I try to understand that person's
belief system as as well as I can
so I don't necessarily deny or defy
anything that they say
I just listen and then I ask them
questions to work out how they came to
that conclusion and then I leave the
discussion not having convinced them but
having a better understanding of why
they believe what they believe
and I think that's far more important
you know because that helps me to better
understand positions that I disagree
with then I will formally maybe I will
attack their beliefs in a piece of
writing you know where I can really
think it through and I don't have
somebody you know moving the goal posts
or anything like that but I'll do that
formally in like an essay I won't do it
in a discussion I found that trying to
change somebody's beliefs in a debate is
almost pointless it's like kind of
change their mind through a rap battle
you know so it's just it works for it
worked for Eminem and Eight Mile but
yeah I I am I'm totally on board with
that and someone asked in a q a a couple
of weeks ago about how I
remain at least partially impartial uh
when it comes to speaking to people and
for me the question asking I I called it
the Socratic method but you've just
called it what was that one
rogerian rhetoric it's different from
the Socratic method because the Socratic
method is an attempt to win an argument
it's basically attempt to ask questions
until you lead somebody into
contradicting themselves or into saying
something that's not true whereas
rogerio rhetoric dispenses with that
completely
rhetoric is purely about um
going to understand the other person's
position from a a neutral objective
point of view so trying to understand
what experiences in their life LED them
to the beliefs that they have have
happened with them now no matter how
wrong those beliefs are you know so if
somebody
um believes that the world is flat
instead of trying to refute that instead
of saying oh you know if you use your
binoculars and you you peer out over the
horizon you'll see that the sales of
ships appear before their prowls you
could say something like that to do to
refute them or what you could do is ask
them so how did you come to this belief
system and what is the evidence that
convinced you and then once you've asked
these questions you get a better
understanding of why they believed what
they believe why they were persuaded by
that and that in itself is valuable
because now you understand why people
believe it which is probably more
valuable to you than understand just
refuting them and changing their beliefs
do you get what I'm saying so it's a
different it's a different value system
it's basically more about understanding
I actually think that that is much
closer to
the position that I take as well because
my goal is very rarely to ask people
questions that make them look stupid up
until the point at which they re recant
all of the opinions that they've got uh
it's much closer to that how do you
spell that first thing
so it's o r v e g e r i a n so Roger i a
n on the end Roger yeah yeah sorry okay
cool so this relates to something that I
wrote about a couple of weeks ago which
is what I've called the soft signal of
Effectiveness triggering a tribal
response is antithetical to having an
effective behavior and belief-changing
message it's nowhere near as sexy to
caveat heavily but when it comes to
important subjects the most compelling
arguments are sometimes the gentler ones
if you care about changing Behavior
you'll dial back the aggression of your
argument
yeah I mean I think I tweeted something
once which was along the lines of um if
you want to convince people show them
that you can be convinced
and I think that works very well in in
life because if you if you show people
that you're open to their arguments and
that you know you're you're willing to
hear what they have to say people are
far more likely to reciprocate because
they see they see you as more of an
open-minded person and they say okay
this person gave me a chance so I'll
give him a chance you know it's like
um if you if you go into an image
straight away trying to win and you
immediately deny what they're saying and
you say that this is wrong this is
instead of actually listening to your
arguments they judge your character they
essentially use Wicken science ruler in
a way
um they they basically form a
personality profile of you and they say
this person is very uh close-minded you
know he's not even listening to he's
just refuted he's trying to refute what
I'm saying he's attacking me and then
they they go into war mode you know they
start red alert and then they basically
want to you know debate you so you you
set yourself up to fail the moment you
try to immediately refute what somebody
is saying I think it's much better just
to sort of um just to listen to them and
again you know use this rogerian return
understand why they believe what they
believe and I mean this shouldn't you
know this shouldn't be
um something that you do just so you can
win an argument you shouldn't just
listen to them so that you can
understand their argument so that you
can beat their argument but it should
really be a goal in itself just to
understand you know that you you have a
better understanding of other people
because it's it's important to
understand why people believe what they
believe just as much as it's important
to believe the right thing
you know so
um it it it helps particularly for
people like you and me who are seeking
to understand human behavior we need to
understand why people adopt false
beliefs and that is much better achieved
by just
having a good conversation with them not
disagreeing with them just asking them
questions about their belief about their
life about why you know what kind of
evidence convinced them what kind of
evidence might convince them that
they're wrong you know and and these
kinds of things and then it makes you
more well equipped to deal with these
beliefs in future as well that's an
added bonus I love that tilting at
windmills an online stranger doesn't
know you all they have are a few vague
impressions of you to meager to form
anything but a Phantasm so when they
attack you they're really just attacking
their own imagination and there is no
need to take it personally
yeah I mean
when I first joined social media
uh started tweeting in 2016.
I used to get quite upset when I used to
get like nasty comments and stuff you
know what people would say stuff and you
know it would get I believe it anyway
I'd be like you know say stuff about me
and I you know they'd call me like um
well I sometimes I'd just be called a
dumb [__] or whatever you know sometimes
people would say that I was a pseudo
intellectual or whatever and and back
then you know I used to sort of think
okay I must have said something that was
wrong you know for them to to think that
and then I realized after a while hang
on a second I don't know anybody
who I um engage with online I don't
actually know any of them I don't even
have an idea of who they are really but
I've convinced myself that I know who
they are so therefore I mean the same
must be happening to other people doing
that to me that they couldn't possibly
know who I really are
you know they've only seen
one or two of my posts and then they
built up a personality profile of Me
based on those two posts you know and I
mean we barely know people that we know
in real life you can live with someone
for five years you still don't really
understand who they are and yet we seem
to think that you know we can read one
post by someone or you know watch one
video by that person and immediately we
think that we know that person and this
is a very powerful illusion that
influences I think almost every in fact
I would say that everybody is afflicted
by this delusion
um where we we just get a tiny snippet
of a person's words or their actions
just a tiny snippet and from that we
just build this massive fictional
character in our heads you know from
that skeleton you know I mean I actually
I think I did tweet something along the
lines of that I'll read it out to you
um yeah this was a tweet I recently sent
actually so I read it so it says um you
are a different character in the mind of
each person who knows you because their
impression of you is made of the bones
of what they've seen fleshed out by a
musculature of Pure Imagination
and I think that really sums up what we
do when we see people online where you
know we just have this Bare Bones just
Bare Bones based on a very brief
interaction with someone and then from
that we create this whole fictional
character who
is very real in our minds but doesn't
actually exist outside of our own heads
and that is a person that we level our
criticism at that is a person that we
level Our Praise at and that is a person
that will defend or attack in arguments
and you know will develop all these
theories about this person who doesn't
actually exist
and that happens all of the time and it
happens I realized it was happening to
me you know people were doing that to me
they would say things about me that just
wasn't true like for instance if I wrote
a tweet that criticized the left
people would say that I was right-wing
but I'm not right-wing at all you know
in fact I'd say that you know I I don't
really have strong political opinions
but I'm probably a Centrist overall
generally I find that you know I agree
with some of the left agree with some of
the right things and just merge them
together but left Wingers when I when I
criticize the left people assume that
I'm like some Far Right guy and they'll
be like you know they'll write oh you're
a crypto fatty fascist and then if I
criticize the right you know
um then so yeah if I crisis right and
people say I'm a globalist libtard you
know all this stuff like you know I'm a
w e f chill or whatever like you know
there's never been a better time to
insult someone than right now
exactly and I'm just there like you know
before this would have really upset me
you know I'd be like just just from the
fact that it was just because I wasn't
used to it I wasn't used to receiving
all this hate but now when I read I
actually read it with a smile on my face
you know I'm just like because I know
that this person is not actually
attacking me they're attacking their own
imagination yes well there's one uh his
maybe a couple of of interesting
considerations to add in there
this is one of the reasons why audience
capture is so dangerous because the only
way that someone can genuinely Tilt at
windmills is if they have an erroneous
view of who you are really compared with
what they've seen of you online but if
your entire Persona has subsumed the
person and you are playing a role on the
internet quite rightly they're pointing
at the person that you are on the
internet and what you've done is you've
basically become cucked by your own
audience you're now this marionette
that's being played by the algorithm to
the point where you do whatever it asks
of you you feed red meat to the to the
Mob so when someone does point the
finger and say you're a globalist shell
or you're a a woke libtard or you're a
right-wing racist or whatever when
someone does say that
where is the firm place for you to stand
where have you got that you can actually
stand if you have sold your soul in
order to gain notoriety online and your
integrity is something that you can't
buy back no matter how much you try and
pay for it
if you've done that where is the you
can't grin when people criticize you
because they're criticizing the
contrived uh monster that you made that
you created yourself into
absolutely and it's a self-reinforcing
feedback loop as well because
like if you're if you're someone like
say um
let's use an example let's use someone
like Temple for instance Tim Paul was
originally sort of like a kind of anti
uh he was he was an occupier Wall Street
guy and he was sort of I'd say quite
Progressive he's quite left and he began
to sort of
flirt with some right-leaning ideas and
he developed a right-wing audience and
over time hit the people on the left who
were formerly followers of his they
began to attack him you know saying oh
you're a right wing chill now you know
you know you're a racist uh sexist
transfer blah blah blah and so they were
attacking this and what happened was
that Tim began to take this time at
least this is what it appears like to me
I don't know him personally but this is
what it seems like to me
um he seems to have taken that to heart
and he became gradually more and more
right wing uh so I mean I would say he's
probably on right now I don't know if he
would agree with that but based on what
I know of his his content he seems to be
pretty firmly conservative although he
calls himself a liberal his his opinions
don't gel with his self-perception so I
think he's a pretty good idea of
somebody who's succumbed to audience
capture
um he he might still think he's a
liberal but all of his guests pretty
much are people on the right or at best
at the center
um he doesn't really have he doesn't
engage with left people very often
um you know the early time that I really
remember him doing that in recent
history was uh with Vijaya Gotti uh on
the Joe Rogan podcast but generally he
seems to be pretty firmly on the right
he's got his
you know his friends are people like the
quartering who are also sort of somewhat
they call themselves liberal but they're
really more slightly to the right
um and I think what's happened is
when left people call people like Temple
out
what happens is this makes an even more
audience captured because he then says
you know I'm a Centrist how could you
call me Roman how can you call me a
racist I'm a Centrist and then he'll say
oh no no it's not me who's moved it's
you who've moved you have gone crazy and
not me and so he'll go even further to
the right and say these people are
absolutely crazy they're accusing me of
being racist and you know so it's like a
self perpetuating cycle and then he
becomes a bit more rowing so then the
left attacking even more say oh you know
you you're a racist so it just keeps
going on and on and on and you know it
happens I think across the Spectrum
that's just one example I mean there are
probably people who have done this
who've moved leftwards and um you know
they've been attacked by people on the
right uh due to that and then they've
gone even more to the to the left as a
result of that and uh so yeah it's it's
a mutual sort of cycle symbiosis there's
another one that I think relates to what
we've just spoken about which is the
principle of humanity every single
person is exactly what you would be if
you were them this includes your
political opponents so instead of
dismissing them as evil or stupid maybe
seek to understand the circumstances
that led them to their conclusions
yeah so I mean this is again this is
part of why rogeri and rhetoric is so
valuable
because
we don't really have a good idea of
anybody that we be only online you know
uh there are people that I've got
relationships with online who I feel
like I know well but I don't I just
don't because all I've seen is what
they've chosen to show me
and when you when all you've seen is
what people have chosen to show you uh
it there are selection effects to that
and you develop a very distorted idea of
of who they are and this causes you to
have assumptions about people and it can
you know just cause you have completely
skewed reality
um and the thing so if you really want
to understand who somebody really is
a much better strategy is to try to look
at who how they became who they were put
yourself in their shoes
and to reflect on
their own internal Logic the internal
logic of their own actions to try to
understand because you've got to bear in
mind that everybody does things that
they think are right for them
you know everybody like every action
that somebody takes they take because
they think it's the right thing to do
even if it's the wrong thing to do they
think it's the right thing to do which
is why they do it so if you can use that
assumption to try to reverse engineer a
person's life experience and find out
why they did the things that they did
then you can develop a much more deeper
understanding than if you simply look at
what they've said online and what
they've done online and you know what's
been said about them or written about
them
these are all going to be things that
are sort of subject to selection effects
you know people are always gonna
comment on the most extraordinary most
wildest wildest things that people have
done they're not going to comment on the
the more mundane things that people do
in their lives you know for every crazy
uh cancelable thought that a person has
they have a thousand opinions that are
just run-of-the-mill and one day yeah
but what happens is that if somebody
says one thing that you don't like you
know you're you're basically just
regard that one thought in that entire
galaxy of thoughts that is their mind
and you're just you know you use that
one little thought
to just sort of Judge them and to
dismiss them or
to fall in love with them or whatever
you know yeah and so it's much more
important to have a a full holistic
understanding of a person's life because
what they show on online is just nothing
it's it's just it's the tip of the
iceberg you can't see that massive
iceberg that is all of the things that
are motivating them behind the scenes of
offline you know in their life that's
why uh the Rogan N word cancellation
video didn't hold water because the way
that mainstream media and cancellation
attempts usually work is this is the
Smoking Gun of his racist transphobic
bigoted views that we always knew were
there and we always told you were there
and everyone I had had the inclinations
you remember I said I thought Joe Rogan
was a racist and this is the tip of the
iceberg the issue that you had with
Rogan his protective mechanism was that
even a casual fan of his may have
listened to 200 or 500 hours and you
know there's some people out there that
have listened to thousands and thousands
of hours of him they say you're telling
me this is the tip of the iceberg I've
seen the whole Iceberg I know that
there's nothing lurking down there and I
have reliable difficult to falsify
evidence that suggests that Joe is a
reliable good non-biggeted guy and that
asymmetry it's the vacuum and the holes
with in somebody's uh personality
Persona
um that gets filled by speculation and
accusation from the Press
and if you have a sufficiently large
body of work and a sufficiently big
audience that's been exposed to enough
of it that's actually protective in that
regard
yeah this is why cancel culture is
fundamentally elitist and fundamentally
anti-left and I try to use this argument
before I wrote an essay about why cancer
culture is not actually left wing
um because the only thing that cancel
culture can cancel is people who don't
really have much social media presence
people who don't have much clout people
who are largely powerless there are
occasional exceptions but you know in
order in order for this to be an
exception you have to do something
that's extremely
um Beyond The Pale like you know sexual
assault something like that
um if you just make a comment about
something
um then
you're going to get canceled if you
don't have much clout but you won't be
canceled if you have a lot of clout and
a lot of people know you well online you
know famous people very very rarely get
canceled for just one thing that they
say whereas poor people or people who
are just ordinary people you know like
that that that lady I always think of
that lady who um I don't even remember
her name which is telling I suppose but
uh you know she said that she was going
to go to
um she was on gonna hop on a flight to
Africa and she was she wanted people to
pray for her that she didn't get AIDS or
something like that it's a small joke
yeah yeah that was like just a
thoughtless yeah it was a stupid tweet
it was just a thoughtless tweet that how
many thoughtless tweets do people send
or you know thoughtless posts that
people don't even think about they just
post it just thinking that it's being
funny I've done that plenty of times
I've not
said anything probably that stupid but
I've said stuff that's almost as stupid
as that
um and you know it's it could have been
any one of us who said something like
that really and it was just off the cuff
she did it before she got up into the
plane when she got off the plane she
realized that life was blown up and
pretty much everybody knew who she was
and now she was yeah her life was over
you know which is it was really it was
actually quite sad but it was I mean it
was weirdly amazing but it was also
really sad like because she did lose
um uh her livelihood as a result of that
and
if she was more famous she wouldn't have
lost that livelihood because not only
because of the things that you just
mentioned about people would know from
her past experience she probably wasn't
a racist person you know she there are
plenty of people that I know personally
who are not racists who occasionally
make jokes about race you know uh who
you know it just happens it's just it's
just a commonplace thing but people
online act as though if you make one
joke that's mildly racist that means
that you literally want to start a
holocaust and you know you want to wipe
out non-white people or whatever like
you know
there's a massive difference between
those two things you know there's
there's people who joke about racism but
they wouldn't judge somebody by their
race in the real world they wouldn't you
know uh they wouldn't do that but then
there's people out there who who would
do that and then the two groups often
get confused and this happens a lot but
if you actually know somebody like Joe
Rogan in your example if you have a long
history of of listening to that person
then you get you realize that they're
one of the the group that might
occasionally say something that's
offensive but isn't one of those people
isn't like a racist isn't perceptive you
know so I wonder if uh I wonder if this
relates to is it brandolini's law and
concept creep so as a particular social
uh
problem becomes uh more rare the
definition of that needs to be expanded
and with brandolini's law as the living
standards in the society rise people's
expectations rise along with it
yeah so that's the first one you've got
correct there that's uh yeah uh the
second one is not Brandon Lee's law
that's cocktail Paradox I knew it I
bloody I bloody knew it but yeah you've
got all the other ones correct though so
that's definitely I knew that there
would be a [__] quiz at some point
right next one next one um overblown
implications effect we think people
judge us by a single success or failure
but they don't if you mess up one meal
no one thinks you're a bad chef and if
you have one great idea no one thinks
you're a genius people just aren't
thinking about you that much
yeah I mean I've when I was young when I
was a teenager I used to suffer from
anxiety
um you know I used to when I would enter
a room I would immediately feel like
everybody was looking at me and I would
feel like my every micro movement of my
body was being sort of analyzed you know
like as if is like literally like I was
on a reality TV show or something and um
it really was like almost paralyzing
experience and it took me a long time to
really realize that hang on a second I'm
just not that important like most people
just do not give a [__] about me you
know and it was such a liberated feeling
because it's it's true for a start but
also you know it just helps you to
realize
um
to basically take away you know if if
you're focusing on what other people
think about you you won't really live
your life how you want to live it you
won't have that sense of Independence
you'll be completely dependent on what
other people think or what you think
other people think about you
but in reality
people just don't care people are more
worried about how they appear to you
than about how you appear to them
um you know
like 10 years ago if I was to go on this
show like you've got 750 000 subscribers
right if I was here thinking about what
750 000 people are thinking about me
yeah while I'm saying this this stuff
right now I'll be paralyzed I wouldn't
be able to do anything I'd be here like
stuttering and I'd just be like you know
I wouldn't be able to say anything
because I just my mind would be
completely filled with the thoughts of
750 000 people thinking of me the way I
look at it is people are going to watch
this episode they'll probably take some
good things from it hopefully if all
goes to plan uh but they won't really
remember
me much they won't remember my mistakes
that I said you know whatever if I said
something wrong they won't really
remember it
um they won't focus on it they're not
gonna stalk me I'm not attractive enough
to be stalked so I don't really need to
worry about all of these things you know
um you know I'm just basically speaking
too soon mate
yeah
well I think it takes something quite
drastic for that to happen but like um
yeah I mean generally speaking I'm you
know
I find that
you just end up another thing is that
you actually end up looking a lot better
to other people if you don't care too
much what they think of you and this is
not to say that you shouldn't I'm not
you know into that whole you know you
should give a [__] and all that [__] I
don't think that's that's really good I
think you should care what people think
but you shouldn't
um you shouldn't be constantly focusing
on what they think of you you know you
should you should just make an effort
just to be relaxed and just to be
yourself
um not not because of
you know like you you want people to
um
I mean really I think the main reason I
want P I think that you should try to be
yourself is because if you try to be
someone who's fake
then you have to essentially create
that character and you have to become
that character so it essentially is a
Prelude to audience capture
um you know if you try to be someone
you're not if you're constantly focusing
on how you appear to others you'll stop
being who you really are and you'll
begin to play to that audience and
you'll essentially be acting in the
Limelight of their gays
and you will cease to be who you
actually are which is I think it's
dangerous I spoke about this in a tedx
talk a couple of years ago and I said
that the Persona is incapable of
receiving love it can only receive
praise and it was something I learned
from Aubrey Marcus that if you're only
playing a role then any compliments that
you receive won't existentially connect
with you inside because it doesn't feel
like someone's complimenting you they're
just complimenting this projection of
what you thought they wanted which is I
don't know I mean sure if you do a
shadow puppet that's really good
fantastic well done look at what you
created but it's not the same as someone
saying you as an individual this very
natural unencumbered projection of your
very essence that you've brought forward
into the world combining all of your
predispositions and genetics with life
experiences and traumas that is worthy
of love and acceptance and praise and
all the rest of it like that's so
fulfilling and it was one of the things
that I you noticed transitioning from an
industry where I I did have to be more
performative oddly had to be more
performative as a guy stood on the front
door of a nightclub than a guy that
talks on a podcast
um I found that I would do and say
things that were incongruous with who I
really was even though I wasn't
necessarily doing the self-assessment to
realize it it's only in retrospect that
I got to to work out that I was playing
this role but someone would ask me my
opinion and I would think okay what does
gwynda want to hear from me at this
moment what what should I say in order
to engender the most positive response
that I can get from him and it was
[__] crippling like it was it was
absolutely crippling because I'm
permanently playing this meta me game
I'm always having to be one degree of
separation removed I don't actually have
an opinion I don't actually hold any
truths myself what I hold are various
avatars that I all need to exist in my
mind at one time because the the you
that I am the me that I am for you and
the me that I am for my housemate and
the me that I am for my mum and the me
that I am for all of the other people in
my life all need to be very carefully
held and and remembered and what did I
say to him last time what was my opinion
about that did I think it was going to
be Tommy Fury or Jake Paul that was
going to win and like all of that all of
that it's incredible computationally
it's basically impossible it is yeah I
mean there's a quote that's been
attributed to um Mark Twain I don't know
if he actually said it but it's
attributed to him and it's um something
like uh if you tell the truth then you
don't need to remember anything and I
think that that really saves you a lot
of energy you know if you are just who
you really are and you just are relaxed
and just say what you really think and
you don't try to put on a front
it just saves so much energy in in
interactions you know I used to be
exhausted in interaction social
interactions because I was constantly
acting I was constantly trying to
impress or I was constantly trying to be
the person that I thought people
expected me to be and it like you said
you know it's just this constant sort of
computational
sort of power like just to be you know
your brain is being Fried by all this
you know circuitry firing off and um
it's just not good because you end up
not being who you really are and you end
up taxing yourself you end up sort of
exhausting yourself uh to be someone who
you you who you're not and at the end of
it all people probably don't even
[__] remember so yes after all of
them didn't even [__] care yeah
let's get let's try and get one or two
more rings that some of these are so
good and I've got enough to do another
episode that we haven't got through so
meme theory an ideology parasitizes the
Mind changing the host's behavior so
they spread it to other people therefore
a successful ideology the only kind we
hear about is not configured to be true
it is configured only to be easily
transmitted and easily believed
yeah I think this idea is one of my
favorite ideas because I think it
explains so much of the information
landscape
uh if you if you look at the sort of the
dominant ideologies on the on the
internet right now
you'll see that they're all
adapted evolutionarily adapted for
nothing else than their own propagation
um and so I mean we would like to use
the sort of work ideology as an example
because it's one of the most prominent
ideologies right now
um and workersm is very powerful idea in
terms of it's a very fertile idea it
spreads very quickly because
it allows people to Signal uh compassion
open-mindedness cosmopolitanism and all
of these very highly prized social uh
forms forms of Social Capital basically
uh so that if you know if something is
good at making people look good then
it's obviously going to be adopted like
a fashion that's that's the very
definition of a fashion a fashion is
something that emerges that in the
current age makes people look like
they're sophisticated clued up
Cosmopolitan you know all of these
things and that's exactly what mochism
does the claims of workers are more
false um you know if you look on
Wikipedia that they're presented as fact
so for instance implicit Association
tests they're pure pseudoscience and
yeah if you go on Wikipedia you'll see
that you know Wikipedia will claim that
implicit Association tests can can
determine whether someone is a racist or
not the fact of the matter is is that in
experiments implicit Association tests
um are about as reliable as lie
detectors you could give somebody the
same implicit association test twice and
have radically different results each
time in fact that's what often happens
so they don't really measure anything
apart from what you're thinking at a
specific moment in time but because if
you believe in implicit Association
tests and you believe in implicit bias
and all this other stuff and white
fragility and everything else that comes
from that then suddenly you're clued up
especially if you're a white person if
you're a white person who believes in
white fragility then this signals oh
look look I'm a white person but I hold
white people to uh account for you know
their crimes against black people so
therefore I'm a very selfless person you
know I'm doing things that are not in my
own interests so therefore I'm very
compassionate person I'm very altruistic
and all this it signals very very
powerful things to other people online
and that's one of the reasons why wokism
has become such a powerful force in the
world
um and you know it's it's not just work
as a moment we can use other examples we
can use the the posing ideology we can
use baptism you know being base being
red pilled
um this idea that you know uh you should
just not care what anybody else thinks
you should be who you want to be and all
this sorts this idea is very powerful
because
it signals to others that you are strong
that you um you don't fold uh but you
know when you're met with the uh sort of
the the mob the the work more but you
don't you know you're basically your
independent minded and all this other
stuff so
a lot of these in fact all of the
dominant ideologies now they all offer
things uh besides anything epistemic so
they don't have epistemic value they're
not they don't have value in being true
they have a value in what they allow you
to signal to others
and so this is really why these
ideologies are so powerful it's why they
have taken over that's why meme theory
and cultural paratism Parasite by the
way this is an idea that was originally
formulated by Richard Dawkins
um I adapted it a little bit in my in my
tweet uh to sort of uh you know just
sort of sum it up in one tweet but yeah
the original credit for this idea uh
comes from Richard Dawkins uh he was the
first to realize I mean he applied this
idea to religion because he saw that you
know religion is not configured to be
true it's configured to be easily
disseminated and easily believed and you
know in his view what gave religion
value was not its epistemic claims but
the idea that it gives people comfort
from death it allows them to it gives
the meaning to their lives it gives them
purpose it gives them something to uh
aspire to
um and then people like Nasim Nicholas
taleb and Jordan Peterson added new uh
benefits to it saying that it was also
an ancestral memory which helped to
codify uh culture and people's ideas
that work sort of thing so um you know
it was basically like a kind of uh it
was a repository of knowledge religion
was a repository of knowledge through
which people would um encode ideas that
worked in in everyday life
tell you what's interesting is something
that I've noticed a lot of people who
10 20 40 years ago would have been very
anti-religion you know
forthcoming atheists now uh lamenting
the loss of something that looks an
awful lot like religion Douglas Murray
is a great friend but you know he wrote
The Strange death of Europe he talked
quite heavily about the the problems
that occurred there uh and he wasn't
exactly one of the Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse but he wasn't like he was
tangential to to that group and
obviously Sam Harris as well but
Douglas's second last book The Madness
of crowds was all about the collapse of
grand narratives the whole purpose was
that we have lost ourselves in the world
and that people are now praying at the
altar of pretty shitty Gods Sam Harris
as well talking about similar lines I
haven't spoken to either of them about
you know what are your views on religion
but I think that both of them would say
bloody hell it would be nice if we had a
grand narrative that held the entire
nation together and gave people a shared
sense of of belonging what do you
think's going on there is that has the
vacuum that's been left by the exit of
religion allowed even worse things to be
sucked in and are people now wondering
how much baby was thrown out with the
bathwater
this is a question that has occupied me
for a very long time and I'm gonna be
I'm gonna write a long essay about this
at some point uh because I've been
entertaining this idea for for years and
I do I do accept that I think I'm one of
those people I was one of the new
atheists sort of crowd kind of people I
mean I wasn't I wasn't one of like you
know I wasn't sort of a famous person or
anything but I was somebody who grew up
um listening to Christopher Hitchens and
Sam Harris and people like that and you
know I am
I did think that religion was pretty
much an unmitigated disaster for a long
time and then with the rise of wokeness
and uh and these alternative ideologies
let us let us give you this
and then um I realized that hang on a
second I mean I was also influenced I
was somewhat influenced by the ideas of
people like uh there's a great
evolutionary psychologist called Steve
Stewart Williams he's a professional at
the University of Nottingham understood
the universe is the best evolutionary
psychology book of all time
yeah absolutely yeah I would I would
definitely recommend that as anybody who
wants like a a good grounding in
evolutionary theory should read that
because it's easy to understand and it's
very colorfully written and it's just
beautifully explained
um yeah I mean from his work and also uh
from the work of a few other uh thinkers
I I sort of realized that hang on a
second religion actually did have some
kind of a function I mean I don't think
Steve actually made this um claim
himself but he he had his he had an
adjacent claim which was that culture is
the means by which we
um codify uh sort of heuristics
essentially so you know we we justify
heuristics by
um sort of uh giving them this kind of
divine Authority and that's how they
survive through the generations they're
passed from one generation to the next
useful heuristics for living life
um for instance you know like avoiding
um uncooked pork or whatever like you
know because of the trichinosis and
other parasites yeah what is it the uh
literally
uh uh was it
figuratively true but literally false
yeah absolutely yeah and he Steve
Stewart Williams has this idea called
cumulative culture which is the idea
that
look individually you and I
are not very smart we don't really we if
we were left alone in this world we
would not survive for very long the only
reason we have
um the value the sort of information
that we have and the knowledge that we
have is because of all the information
that was transmitted to Our Generation
by past Generations through culture so
it's because we're part of this culture
that we have learned all of the things
that our previous generations learned
and survived to tell the tale you know
so you know if we were just an isolated
individual with no past we would we
would not have like we would we would be
born in this world
we would probably gain a rudimentary
understanding of things like gravity
because things would fall when we you
know if we dropped to Apple it would
fall so we would realize okay gravity is
a thing we wouldn't call it gravity but
we would just know it as a force that
causes things to fall to the Earth and
then from there we would gradually and
very slowly
just very slowly accumulate information
but the fact of the matter is is that
there are people who have been there
before us who have learned all of these
things before and they supercharge our
knowledge when we're born because when
we go to school we learn about gravity
we learn about all of these other things
that have happened all the things are
passing so we are the sort of cumulative
experience of all past generations and
religion is the means by which this
information is transmitted from
generation to generation that's why I
call it an ancestral memory
because it's like a memory for our
species as a whole
and so there is value I think there is
value in religion that's one thing
another aspect of religion is that it it
does preserve a sense of order
which we've seen collapse now with you
know the sort of Rise of crazy gender
ideology and all sort of stuff
um you know religion did have a certain
purpose in that it it kept people in
this
sort of system where things were
structured and there was you know order
essentially there was it we impose order
on a chaotic World by inventing myths
and by following these myths as if they
are the law
and so there is that kind of value I
didn't appreciate that until relatively
recently and I think I I actually did a
lot of research into this and I found
that yes Wellness I think has definitely
at least in part been caused by the
abandonment of religion and I say this
as an atheist I'm I'm a staunch atheist
I'm convinced um that there is no God
but at least not in this universe there
might be in other universes but at the
same time I also I accept that the loss
of religion uh did play a part in the
rise of hopelessness and this this can
actually be traced because
um there if you look at one of the ways
that um vocalist became such a big issue
where it became such a big ideology it
was through something called atheism
plus which was
um a movement that sort of arose
at the tail end of new atheism
um when a group of people
on the left like PC Myers who's a
biologist
um he was one of the leaders of the
movement
they basically um
came to the conclusion that if we if if
new atheism is going to kill religion
we're going to need something to replace
it we're going to need a new system of
values
and
basically kickstarted this movement of
new atheists basically that decided that
the best way to the best thing to
replace uh religion with is social
justice so they came up with this thing
called atheism Plus
and this was a massive thing I mean this
you know people a lot of people who were
part of this ended up becoming involved
in things like gamergate and a lot of
the early woke combat with the sort of
bright
um began out of this uh there was a A
lady called a forgotten named Rachel
uh do you remember the lift incident
where there was a there was a atheist I
think her name was Rachel's Rachel
something I forgotten her name but she
was quite prominent around 2012 20 2011
2012. basically she was a new a new
atheist who became like one of the the
main sort of people in atheism plus and
she had this um sort of uh incident in a
lift where a guy uh joked about going to
the lingerie section or something and
she said it was like misogynistic and it
kicked up a massive fuss and even
Richard Dawkins got involved what was
her name Rachel Rachel Watson I think
her name was let me just quickly check
it online just to show you I don't want
to incriminate the wrong person and
accuse the wrong Rachel Watson
yeah yeah
Rachel Watson um
I think her name was Rachel Watson
something like that but it's not
important I mean
I'm sorry Rebecca Watson it was Rebecca
Watson
yeah Rebecca Watson but yeah she was one
of them and then Matt Dillahunty was
another guy uh he was another one who
who was part of this movement and then
the aforementioned pz Mize and what they
did is basically these people went
extremely hard into the whole social
justice stuff but they went so hard they
were they basically led to the rise of
this uh website called rational Wiki
have you heard of that
and that's now like it's probably just a
a laundry list of all of the Unspeakable
people from the right
yeah and Russia Wiki emerged out of
atheism plus it's basically rational
Wiki is is the worst okay it's not the
worst website on the internet but it's
it's the worst website that appears on
the first page of Google search results
uh for most searches it's quite a
popular website but it's um because a
lot of people see the term rational Wiki
and they assume that it's rational they
assume that it's a rationality anything
but yeah exactly it basically exists
just to um shame people for having views
that are not woke basically
and this was a major this was a major
facilitator of wokeness in the first
half of the 2010s and even in sort of
like the first half of the 2000s I think
so the latter half of the 2000s
um because this was really like a
massive Push by new atheists who wanted
something to replace the loss of
religion with and they found it in
social justice and then that movement
gradually it dotailed with critical race
Theory and with critical theory critical
theory and critical race Theory are two
different things
um and um you know gender ideology and
also the stuff they all dovetail
together and they sort of formed
vocalists the Great Awakening which was
in the sort of you know 2012 2013. but
atheism plus was a major
um a sort of facilitator what was um
nobody has written about this so far but
I've done a lot of research into it and
I'm going to write an essay on this at
some point get
um the article written mate look dude
let's let's bring this one home
everybody needs to subscribe to your sub
stack everyone that is listening why
should they go for that and what else
should they follow
so uh yeah sub stack is is
g-u-r-w-i-n-d-e-r uh dot substant.com uh
it's much better if I should spell out
the name because people never know how
to spell my name and my Twitter is G
underscore s underscore
b-h-o-g-a-l uh
what are you gonna write next
so
the next thing I'm working on is about
uh the AI misinformation explosion and
how it is actually a good thing it's not
a bad thing it's actually a good thing
yeah it's gonna that's one hell of a
[__] open loop Jesus Christ yeah
you see the uh Elliot yukowski is
believes that language learning models
are causing so much of a problem that
he's uh removed his sabbatical from
doing podcasts
I actually watched it I watched his
podcast recently there's a podcast
entitled something like we're all gonna
die or something like that and I thought
okay I've got to watch this because you
know I respect Eliza I think he's a very
smart guy
um and I I agree with a lot of what he
says I don't agree with everything he
says
I think he does slightly oversell the
threat of AI but not by much not by much
I think a lot of his points are very
important he's a and I think
a much needed counterweight to the oh
it's just they're just telling their
utopianism
yeah absolutely yeah and I will I will
be covering his theories at some point
as well I'm going to be writing a lot
more often now
um because I'm going to be here
just doing this full time I've been
meaning to do this full-time sub step
full-time I haven't gotten around to it
yet but I'm going to be doing this thing
full time very soon and I'm going to be
churning out articles a lot more often
good yeah that's good for me that gives
me more stuff to talk about that gives
me more excuses to bring you back on I
absolutely adore every time that you
come on everyone needs to go subscribe
to your sub stack and follow you on
Twitter dude until next time I
appreciate you
thanks Chris always a pleasure what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
face
foreign